you know people ask me sometimes that so
it's an interesting discussion this high
definition dreamin thinking about your
future very very very clearly it's kind
of a nerdy exercise if you think about
it but then it's really not it's kind of
a dreamer exercise you know Sharon and I
when we first started this company our
kids were little and people say how did
you work the hours that you work to
start and then grow that company and you
were gone all the time and how did you
do that and your children survived in
your marriage survived and all that it's
because we weren't looking at the moment
we were looking past the moment we were
living like no one else so that later we
could live and give like no one else so
like if I was going out on a book tour
and I was gonna be gone for six weeks
just like forever for somebody like me I
can't stand being gone that long but for
six weeks since Sharon's left there with
three little kids which is like torture
how does she get through that and not be
bitter at me at the company how do I get
through that and I get so homesick I
can't breathe because we're living like
no one else so that later we can live
like no one else and we told the kids
hey this book is paying us some good
money so we're gonna go do this and when
I get home about six weeks later after I
get home we're going to Disney World
so you you know you paint a
high-definition picture out there in the
future
that allows you to walk through the crap
you have to walk through to win and
that's true in anybody's life you know
nobody good if people go the why and
workout because it's fun but there's
just a few of them most people that go
work out they work out because they they
are gonna they're gonna go through that
pain to get the result you got to go
through the pain to get the result
that's what it comes down to but you got
to have the result clearly defined in
your mind and the more clearly defined
it is the more you're able to walk
through the garbage that's necessary to
win
[Music]